so let's think about the graph of y is
equal to the principal root of x and
then we'll start playing around with
this and see what happens to the graph
so y is equal to the principal root of x
well this is going to be undefined if
we're if we want to deal with real
numbers for X being any negative value
so the domain here is really X is
greater than or equal to zero when x is
0 Y is going to be equal to 0 when X is
1 the principal root of 1 is positive 1
so it's going to be like that
when X is 4 the principal root of 4 is 2
when X is 9 the principal root of 9 is 3
so this is what it is going to look like
it just couldn't look more like and look
more like more like this so it's going
to look something like that that's my
best attempt at actually graphing it now
let's think about what happens if we
wanted to shift it in some way so let's
say we wanted to shift it up let's say
we wanted to shift it up by 4 so how
would we do that well whatever value
we're getting here we just want to we
want Y to be 4 higher so we could just
add 4 to it so we could just use Y is
equal to the square root of x plus 4 so
that would be like taking this graph
right over here so let me copy and then
let me paste it so it's like taking this
graph and we're shifting it up 1 2 3 4
it would look it would look like it
would look like that well that was that
was pretty straightforward let me do it
in that same blue color so that you
recognize that that's that one right
over there
but what if we wanted to what if we
wanted to shift it let's say to the left
let's say we wanted to do something like
this
let's say we wanted to shift it to the
left by 3 like that so how would we how
would we define the function then and
I'll do this in this orange color in
this orange color we want to shift by 3
so you're shifting to the left by 3 so
think about it this point y equals is
zero right over here where whatever you
put under the radical was equal to zero
so what do you have to put under the
radical here to get zero well here X is
negative three so if you put X plus
three under the radical then you are
going to get the square and you take the
square root of that you're going to get
zero so this right over here this orange
function that is why let me do it over
here y is equal to the square root of x
plus three and once again I might be
counterintuitive we went from square
root of X 2 square root of x plus 3 when
we added 4 outside of the radical that
shifted it up but when we add 3 inside
of the radical inside of the radical
instead of shifting it to the right
instead of shifting it that way it
shifted it to the left it made it it
made this point go from zero to negative
3 and the important thing to realize is
what makes y equal to 0 over here y
equals 0 when x is 0 over here and over
here y is equal to 0 when X plus 3 is
equal to 0 or X is equal to negative 3
and you could do that for other points
to see that it does definitely shift to
the left and that's an important thing
to realize this isn't actually just for
radical functions this is actually for
functions in general if you just kind of
add a 4 at a number out here whatever
you add is going to shift it up or down
if you this was a minus 4 it would have
shifted it down but within when you
replace the X with an X plus 3 when you
replace it with an X plus 3 this
actually shifted it to the left of I 3
if you wanted to shift it to the right
by 3 you would put an X minus 3 over
there
well that's all interesting but let's
say let's say that I wanted to I wanted
to flip this thing over so I wanted it
to look like this see if I can draw it
I want this graph to look to look
something like that try my best to to
look something like something like that
so it's it's flipped so it's flipped
around I could do a better job than that
so so we have the point that point on it
and
and we're going to go three and then up
we're going to have that point on it so
I want it to look actually I do a decent
job the first time I drew it I want it
to look something like that so
essentially I want to take it's it's
mirror image
a lot around the line X is equal to
three how could I do that well now my
domain is different now my domain it
should be undefined for anything where X
is greater than negative three and it
should be defined for any X that is less
than or equal to negative three or
another way to think about it is we need
to flip the sign of whatever we have
under the radical so this thing over
here let me actually scroll over a
little bit this thing over here in green
could be Y is equal to the square root
of the negative of X plus three and I
encourage you to try some X values here
to try it out what we've done is we've
essentially flipped flipped what happens
under the radical now in order to get a
positive value on the under the radical
now X plus three has to be negative and
the only way that X plus three is
negative or the only way that X plus
well the only way that X plus three is I
guess you say non positive is if X is
less than negative three
now what if we wanted to do something
even more interesting what if we wanted
to flip this what if we wanted to flip
this one right over here over over the
horizontal axis over y equals zero well
then we're just flipping what route we
take so that would be Y is equal to the
negative square root of negative x plus
three so it would look like this it
would look like it would look like this
it would look like that and if we wanted
to shift that thing we could just add or
subtract something outside of the
radical so let's say we wanted to do let
me copy and paste this let's say so
let's copy and
let's let's say that we wanted to shift
it down here so instead of beginning at
y equals zero right over here we're at y
equals negative four then we would just
subtract four outside of the radical so
this thing and this thing I'm running
out of colors here this thing right over
here would be y is equal to negative
square root of negative x plus three
minus four minus four and so we could
keep going on and on and on but
hopefully this gives you a sense of the
different ways you can manipulate this
thing and we'll do some more examples to
get a better understanding of it